[MUSIC PLAYING]
WILLIAM R.: I'm
coming from a family--
seven children, three sisters,
four brothers, and my parents.
We were living an average
life, a very religious life.
My father, he was
an Orthodox Jew.
And I went to Haida.
I went to Polish school.
And I learned a trade.
MALKA B.: What I remember
from my childhood
was a small family,
not very wealthy.
We all lived in--
in a neighborhood which
later was the ghetto.
My father was a printer,
had a printer shop,
and worked there with a helper.
My mother was a housewife.
We were two children.
We used to walk to
school quite a long time.
It took an hour
perhaps, and on foot.
We met, children together,
so we did not walk alone,
and, um, talked.
And we were excited and
studied poetry on the way.
So it was sort of nice.
LEON G.: We had nine children.
We had, you know, five
brothers and four sisters.
We are, right now,
already at three--
two brothers and one sister.
We had also two nephews and
a grandfather in our house.
And we remain only three
of us from all of them,
all of them when.
Living in Czestochowa, we
had a shop from tailoring.
My father was a tailor.
We all children worked in
the shop, in the tailoring.
We had a wonderful time as kids.
We are-- there we played.
We belonged to a
Zionist organization.
We played ping pong,
football, anything.
What we had was
a wonderful time.
WILLIAM R.: I personally
live a social, a good life--
I would say, the average life--
because, in my time, that
time, I had a good trade.
And I was mating--
making family.
So, at that time, if you
had enough to feed yourself
and to buy for yourself nice
clothes and, once a week,
if you was able to go to a
movie with your girlfriend,
that was a luxury.
LEON G.: I person
who ask of, uh, you
know, a kid over there something
like that-- how come, you know,
you don't play this and that?
Well, he said you were Jewish.
I said, what's the difference?
So he said, you killed Christ.
I said, what do
the-- oh, uh, well,
how-- and I didn't understand,
you know, what they are--
you know.
He said, you killed Christ.
I said, I didn't kill him.
What do you want from me?
He said, you killed him.
So that was a very-- the--
the religion, you know,
was, uh, got, uh, a lot of
thing to do in-- in the school.
In the city, we had three
miles away from-- from where
we lived over there, we had
the holy shrine over there.
WILLIAM R.: In Czestochowa--
in Polish, you say Czestochowa,
that was the biggest church.
Whoever you talked to--
and if-- then he going to
tell you the same thing,
that Czestochowa was the
biggest anti-Semitic city.
LEON S.: I make so much money.
You know, I was
working two shifts.
And I was both shifts
in the-- in the factory.
And I was working.
And then I had two children.
And really I had a bitter
life, beside money.
I mean, money was
not questioned.
It's like, uh-- so
this bitter life
was this was one
child was retarded.
LUDWIG F.: In 1933,
we had been married.
And we had a child
in 1937, a girl.
And, uh, I was a very
successful businessman.
PAULA K.: My father
knew his politics.
He was all his life in this.
So I heard then that I
was a child from 19--
I was born in 1924.
But, in 1928, I was a little
child, five years, six years.
I always hear whole nights
he used to stay at the radio
and hear all his speeches.
At that time, I didn't
understood who's-- who was
speaking, you know.
But, later, I found out.
He knew it is going
to be something.
LEON G.: Oh, we didn't, uh, we
didn't understand too much, you
know, what's going on, you see.
We didn't know.
And, even, they said, you
know, Hitler is in Palestine.
You're going to go to Palestine.
You're going to get--
Hitler is coming, or
something like that.
You killed Christ.
We didn't, uh-- you know,
we didn't know nothing.
As, you know-- I didn't
know it was, uh, you know,
was going to be so bad.
See, we wasn't organized.
See, nobody told
nothing, you know.
Even, when you-- even
when you want to go away,
the father didn't
want to let you.
You didn't want to leave
your father and mother.
You stood with the
family all together now.
We wasn't trained to have a gun.
We wasn't trained
to have a knife.
We wasn't trained to know
about this kind of business
over there.
You know, stay away from us.
Stay away.
You stay away.
We didn't-- we wasn't
nothing, you know.
We just worked and
all, went to school.
And we went to
the Polish school.
We went to Hebrew school.
And, uh, and we go home
and work, uh, in the house.
PAULA K.: Well, I
was in the street,
and one day, bombs coming down.
So everybody start to go back
to their houses and running.
It was already that time
a lot of people killed.
And we hide it, so
didn't took too long.
MALKA B.: In '39 when Germans
took off over Czestochowa,
after very, very short fight,
during that time, we ran--
my family and I, I remember
hiding in a cellar.
Probably when they
bombarded the city.
And hiding from the Germans.
LEON G.: From Czestochowa to
the border, from German border,
was only 25 miles.
You know, we was only,
not too far away from,
from them over there.
That's why they was, in
1939, they started Friday.
And Sunday, 10 o'clock, they
was already in the city.
It could be they
was there at night.
I didn't see it, because
at night I was sleeping.
But that day, Saturday, I walked
out, and I see them fighting.
And Sunday morning, when
I walked out over there,
it was 10 o'clock,
I took a walk.
Three miles up to the
city hall over there,
it was three miles from my house
to the city hall over there,
I took a walk over there.
We see the German was already
all over, occupied the city.
There was a friend of my father,
and I walked out over there,
went in over there.
His son was a friend
of mine over there.
You know, we, I know that.
Also tailor.
His name was Mr. Blitz.
And he said to me, now it's
time to kill ourself, that man.
And I looked at him, I didn't
know what he was talking about.
And I went up to the city
hall, and I went away--
I ask this son if he want to
go for a walk, he said no.
So I went myself.
I went up three
miles over there,
and saw the Germans and all,
the city hall, I wanted to see.
They put the German flag up
and everything like that.
I see the whole story.
And after, when I walked
back, I walked back,
and in the evening, I
went again over there,
and he was killed already.
INTERVIEWER: Who was?
LEON G.: He throwed
him-- that Mr. Blitz.
So he went up on
the third floor,
and he throw himself down,
and he killed himself.
The next morning,
all the people,
they tell us with the bayonets
over there and everything.
We lost-- the Bloody Monday,
they call it Bloody Monday--
we lost at the Bloody
Monday, 300 to 400 people.
They just raus, raus, out,
out, out, out, out, out,
with a bayonet and
everything, out, out, and out.
And then they had
that, they, they, they
show you the way to go to
the, to the green over there.
All the bayonet was open
with the guns and everything
like that.
Just like that with
the bayonet, they
was going and all
the thing over there.
This was the Bloody Monday, they
started right in the morning.
And this was our first
day, the first, I mean,
the first day of the
Bloody Monday over there.
LUDWIG F.: They ordered
the whole Jewish population
of that city to get to
certain points, gather,
and the death
happened, they picked
at random, just every so
one, and just shot him.
We were there, and
I was in a barracks
as there were quite a
few thousand people.
And then they just had
been released to go home.
And since then, we
know what to expect.
Every day, another branch
of the German troops
of Germans and Gestapo
of the City Hall
had been picking up people
in the street at random,
whatever they could,
to do their work.
LEON S.: The first of
all, they throw out
the Jews, the rich
Jews, from the houses,
and they took away everything.
They put us between three,
five families in a two,
in a two bedroom apartment.
So I saw it's very bad.
MALKA B.: My father's
printer's shop was closed.
The Germans took
over the machinery.
My school was closed,
so our teachers
decided to continue
education in their homes.
So I remember, we
walked in small groups
to their homes for
further instructions.
Then slowly, one
teacher disappeared,
we didn't know where.
Our doctors disappeared,
It was all hushed, maybe
because I was a child then,
but maybe also people
really didn't know.
It was very gradually done.
There were rumors that they were
taken to another city to work,
or they were needed because
intelligentsia, as we call it,
intelligentsia were slowly
disappearing from the city.
Doctors, professors, teachers,
directors slowly disappeared.
So they were the first to go.
After a while, we
did not study at all.
LEON S.: But they go to
work, people to work.
Any kind of work, not work
what is productive, productive,
only you know, to keep
Jews hard working.
So I said, I am a mechanic.
And I want to do, I can
do any kind of work.
So they took me to work.
What they gave me, I did.
I tried to do the best--
I mean, the best as a mechanic,
not the best for them--
as a mechanic, to
show to be needed.
To can keep there, for the
children, for the house.
WILLIAM R.: So they create the
ghetto, six or seven months
later, when they came
into Czestochowa. 'Cause
this was only 30 or 40 miles
from the German border.
Then we start to feel how
difficult it is to get food,
to get the first aid.
And a Jew was not allowed
to leave the ghetto.
We had some rationing
from the Jewish, they,
they create a Jewish
administration.
And I would say, used to
get 900 or 1,000 calories
for each head.
That was in the beginning.
Later was even not,
less than that.
And between, young
people had to go,
and to work for the Germans.
The Jewish administration
used to point out
who has to go to work.
LOLA J.: We had no
money to live on,
'cause jobs were not available.
So we struggle.
I used to go out of my,
I mean, out of ghetto,
I took off my armband,
and asking my,
my father's friend for help.
This the only way we
survived, just you know,
just whatever we could.
It was very hard.
Begging people, please help me.
We did have some nice people
who my father, rest in peace,
used to help them too.
And they gave me, you know, I
was carrying on my shoulder,
we'll call it the book sack.
It's not, it's, what do
you call that, in the back,
you carry stuff.
INTERVIEWER: Backpack?
LOLA J.: Backpack.
And I was, had potatoes.
Following day, after Yom
Kippur, they surrounded us,
and put us on a big market.
Left and right,
young ones, even two.
We're just plain lucky
that we got in on the side.
My sister and my
mother were separated.
from the
._?}
And I was screaming.
And I said, mama, I was crying.
And one of the who surrounded
us was a Jewish guy who helped,
who had to be helped.
And he said, you be happy,
because you're going to work.
And he shut me up.
I say like, somebody says,
your life is going to be saved.
And I said, mama,
and I screamed.
So he shut me up.
He said, don't scream.
So I was separated from
my sisters, two sisters.
And then this was the end.
MALKA B.: Before
we knew it, there
was a very harsh
knock on the door.
The door burst open.
Assessment came in, with rifles,
out, out, out, out, in German.
And we were forced out.
When-- I never saw my
home anymore after that.
We were taken out into the
street, very fast, very loud.
I probably was shocked, I
didn't know what's happening.
But still I had my mother,
my father, another girl,
young girl who lived with
us, who helped my mother also
was taken.
And they arranged us quickly
with rifles in fives, and five,
and five, and five.
And all my neighbors
were coming out
of their houses and apartments.
And fives, and fives, and
fives were arranged that way,
and marched forward.
And we came to a
certain spot where
the Germans separated people.
And because the five people were
always members of the family,
they knew exactly
what they were doing.
They separated the families.
So for us, my mother
was separated.
Of course, with a gun pointing
to left, right, left, right.
My mother and the girl
who worked with her
were to one side.
My father and my brother
and I, to the other side.
At that point my father
wanted to run to my mother,
to go with her.
Well, they hit him
with a gun, and not
killed him, just set
him, pushed him away,
and he went back to us.
Mother disappeared.
I didn't know then
where she went.
Later I found out that this
was the first transport
to Treblinka.
So she was lost to us.
We did not know where she went.
My father and I and my brothers
remained together for a while.
The Germans sent my
brother and my father
to work on a railroad track.
They sent us to
work somewhere else.
Every day we returned
to the same place
were they stationed us.
And one day, my father and
brother did not return.
Again, I didn't know at that
time what happened to them.
Later I found out from witnesses
that they were both shot
on the railroad in the back.
At that time, I didn't know.
But from that moment
when I was left alone
with other Jews who
were left alone,
without any links
to their family,
and I was barely 15 there.
LUDWIG F.: Every day, a
certain part of the city
has to be gathered in
a certain place where
they have decided which one
has to go right and left.
Which mean dead or to be alive.
MALKA B.: It was HASAG, Hugo
Schneider Aktiengesellschaft,
it was called.
It was a labor camp
in Czestochowa,
somewhere on the
outskirts of the city.
And what we did was, we--
they were bringing shells
from anti-aircraft guns,
or ammunition.
And the shells that were
destroyed, or partially
destroyed, or bent were
restored in that factory.
LUDWIG F.: Now I have
a wife and kid still
in the ghetto, which
hasn't been touched yet.
LEON S.: He knew I
have a sick child.
He said, but us in
Germany, we are not
keeping people like this.
We are giving the injection,
because the, the, the,
country has not a use
for such a people.
If would be my son, I would
do the same, he advised me.
LEON G.: We went with Germans
that were inside in that
HASAG over there, and
we come in over there.
The first thing, they lined
us up, all 300 people.
And we went up one flight.
There was one huge room
for the 300 people.
Was 300 people, 150
laying on one side,
and 150, the other side.
Was only one bathroom there.
And that's the
way we was inside,
and this was the first
day without our parents.
The first cry out that night,
we was choking me and crying.
MALKA B.: I was 15, and I was
one of the youngest in camp.
All younger children
were killed and murdered.
LUDWIG F.: You
have to understand
one thing, that
children two years old,
overnight became 1,000 year old.
They know like rats,
that they will be killed.
LEON S.: I told
you, the first child
was, I have the sick child.
When they liquidate the
ghetto, they took a truck.
And with the truck, they took
people with the children.
Before I came in to
the, my apartment,
the policeman told
me, was he a truck.
And they took, a man went up--
I mean, from the children, Jews.
They went up, and bought
a sleeping child down.
And this was the
end from this child.
LUDWIG F.: They start
to build a small ghetto
from all these people who
were left in the factory.
In order to do that,
they have picked women.
And they marched with
them to that small place
where Jewish people used
to live, and to clean up.
And they were going about 10
,_?}
the women, with pails and
everything which is needed
to clean up, brushes.
My wife took the child, and
put in one of these pails.
And go in, visit 10
,_?}
they went into that little
place where the ghetto will be.
Now going back, she hid
the kids under the bed,
in that little
ghetto, overnight.
And the kid was by herself
until the next day,
she came back again, and
gave her something to eat.
This was for a few days.
And in the end, they
took all of the rest
and put in that ghetto.
And all these people who were
sent to factories to work,
had to go back everyday
into that new ghetto.
Now here again, we are
the whole family together.
LEON G.: We had
one night we went
home, was two guys who fell
asleep in, in the place.
And we was counted to 298.
And we took one guy
out, because every 50,
they had the
responsible one guy.
And they took out the guy,
you know, and they shot him.
Because he didn't know
where the two guys was at.
The next day, the two guys was
there, in the, in the factory.
Nothing would happen
to them over there.
I mean, it's, it was something,
you know, this everything
what I saw it, you know.
It was a young boy, the
same thing, you know.
He was a cap maker, I know him
very good, I see him every day.
I mean, I see him, in my,
my dream, I can see it.
Because we all were together.
LUDWIG F.: So
fortunate that we were
working where the Pope
was, with the Holy Madonna,
the Black Madonnas.
And we got in touch, going
back and forth, you know,
painting you just,
people go back and forth.
With one of the sisters,
and we told them the story,
we were just save our
kid, how to do it.
And we gave them an address,
and a name of our former mate.
Well, whatever they
arranged, that the maid will
be at a certain
time, at that place,
and the kid will just walk out.
And so happened,
she took the child,
and walked with the child
up to the post office.
Over there was
another woman, they
didn't know each other,
who took over the child.
And that woman brought the
child into that monastery,
through a closed door,
and she had to leave.
There can be no witnesses.
Then the door opened,
they took in the child.
The child came in, they
have listed as a nun--
an orphan of a Polish officer.
LEON S.: The other child,
when I left the second place,
I took away, so
I, so I be killed.
Because they always were
joking, next day, next day,
finish, you know.
So I saw, and I had a connection
in the, from the underground,
was an engineer,
electric in HASAG.
He was living outside,
he was in underground.
And he has the job as
electrical engineer
in HASAG, in the
concentration camp
where the metal factory was.
You know, so I saw, maybe in
a day they will kept, keep me,
and then they will
not let me out.
So I have to, I have to give
the child, that person what I
can have a connection with him.
So I asked him, I give
you so much, so much money
to keep my child with
your child, you know.
And he agreed.
And I trust him, because
he was in the underground.
MALKA B.: We were extremely
hungry all the time.
We were getting a piece of
bread maybe that big, dry bread
for the whole day.
So some of us could
resist and take
a little bit in the
morning, a little bit
at noontime, a little
bit in the evening.
But most of us ate it
right away in the morning.
And for lunch, we got some
potato peel soup, water
and potato peels.
For the evening, there were
some ,_?}
some coffee.
And that was what, what
we lived on, three years.
As far as I'm
concerned, I didn't even
hope for being saved.
We just knew that
someday we will die just
like everybody else.
PAULA K.: We looked out through
the windows, we saw, my God,
fights.
The Russian woman, they came,
they had a whole battalion.
And they came and they fought
those Germans, and they were--
I saw so much death again.
MALKA B.: And all of a
sudden, a young Jewish man
ran into the hall, opened the
doors, and told us, come out,
come out, we are free.
The Russians are here, the
Germans are running away.
LOLA J.: Being in, in
camps, being in concentrate,
we were just fighting
for every day.
We never knew.
There was expect
that any day it's
going to happen, something.
But after we were
liberated, we're
sad, because where
we going to go?
Where are you going?
Nowhere is home.
LUDWIG F.: I went
back to Czestochowa,
and yes, I want to
pick up my child.
I know she's in that monastery.
But how are you
going to pick it up?
She's there as an orphan.
So my wife and I went there, and
we start talking to the nuns.
She didn't believe it.
She has no parents.
She's a devoted kid
to Jesus Christ.
The church, well, we just
couldn't let it go like that.
We called in one monk,
and another monk.
And then came the head man.
And we tried to convince
them that this is our child.
But then they came
up with a verdict.
Let the child make
her own choice.
She was walking from one end
to the other, back and forth.
She didn't know what to do.
And finally she
probably recognized me.
And got to me, crying,
I want to go with you.
LEON S.: So one day, there,
there, from the underground,
the, the people stood there,
most people, you know,
there's nothing.
So they saw me in the
street, come with us,
we're going to drink now.
Say, a big, you know, a
party from the underground.
I said, I can't go.
I have to look for my child.
And I can't trust no
more, for the underground,
I don't know where is my child.
So he, he told me, listen,
one, you have to know,
go there and there.
You will hear ever
thing what happened.
And there is a lake,
and I went there.
And I asked the neighbors
around, I knocked on the house.
A woman told me, when
the Germans were here,
somebody brought a child,
was crying, they was waiting.
We went out on the lake
in the, in the morning,
we found a dead child.
Then we saw that,
we told the Germans.
He said, that
child in the water.
And I didn't want to
tell this my wife.
What will help?
I had this in me.
MALKA B.: This is
me, and this is
my friend who had that picture.
She survived with her
father, from the same city.
We were just neighbors,
and very close friends.
And this Helen, and
I are only survivors.
All these children,
these girls were killed,
during the first Aktion.
They were just, as they took
people out, five and five,
they went, they went to death,
and we went to life, life.
WILLIAM R.: We were a
family from 96 people.
Uncles, aunts,
cousins, grandfathers,
and I'm the only one
I'm still around.
LUDWIG F.: People wonder why
we never smile, we never laugh.
This part of our brain is dead.
We don't know what is love.
My child, my daughter
never laughs.
She's now a grown,
wonderful person,
she lives in Los
Angeles, California.
And I have a son who lives in
Atlanta, Georgia who's married.
He went through law school.
So has my daughter.
But the different between
that child's life and my son
is in two worlds.
It was just like coming
back from grave, dead,
without feeling.
Here people live normally,
playing the piano,
having mates, good
times, they laugh.
And here, we have death.
[MUSIC PLAYING]